I want the players to Aspire to be their
best on the field but also to Aspire to
be their best off it with the stuff as
well your second Mountain should be
better than your first we always get
told who do you want to be as a player
but why aren't we asking who do you want
to be as a person I looked around the
room and I went he'll be okay he won't
he'll be okay he won't I was like this
is this is crap man like why w we
leaving this up to chance like it's it's
not right like they love you while I'm
here when it's about winning
championships and I I'll do anything to
break there for you but when that day
ends
it's what a what a what a what an
absolute what a what a what
[Music]
[Applause]
aute ah what a lad well I'm loving how
this podcast has sort of grown into a
platform for people to share their
insights and help others in similar
positions and I'm very grateful for to
have a true lad on today he is Keen to
help players change their mindset around
life after sport throughout his career
the self- acclaimed white battler played
for plenty of teams along the way
including monoa 2 Wellington Hawks Bay
canib and and in Super Rugby he played
for the Hurricanes the Rebels the
Highlanders and the Crusaders he is a
true legend of New Zealand Rugby it is
one of the greats Jed Robinson welcome
mate thanks mate I think all the boys
say when you I'm always interested to
know how you're going to do today it
probably takes the whole podcast the
same what teams have play for jez you
played for a few yeah well you don't go
out to do it that but you got to find a
contract too right you got to chase the
money and where it is so yeah was it
always um was it never really your
decision to to move was it always you
had nothing um no I mean I started off
with the canes we go to the Super um and
there's pretty two pretty good hookers
sitting there with um Andrew wh and Dan
K their stage so coy and me even though
I'm three years older than Coy I was
kind of on that same timeline in terms
of trying to kick off into that stuff
yeah um so I was probably more like Hy
as a starter and then Horry was
obviously playing all the time but then
you've got Coy who's going to be better
off the bench I
wonder and just make gaps and score
tries left right and Center so um I
spent two years there and probably got
half a dozen games but this was back in
the time you'll probably remember this
when if you were wider you could only
play if there was an injury oh yeah yeah
so um Hy got injured on India tour and I
had two or three games um actually
funnily enough the only game I did start
Co you hate the story um so it was a
second week Hy was out for the first
three weeks he said Jade you're in the
squad and then um the second week we're
playing the Crusaders down here at Old
Jade stadium before it went under yeah
and um after the first week Coy had a
few bears and um ended up being put in
put in the cells for a drunken
disorderly and Company and power oh I
remember him telling that Yan on his
podcast and uh so I rock up on Monday um
so there's only three of us and then
they go uh Co is not allowed to play
this week he's been banned for a week
for his for his behavior um so Jade
you're starting against Crusaders so I
have I've played 10 minutes of Super
Rugby yeah you're starting against
Crusaders and we've got no other hooker
in the squad so had to go 80 so they
said mate Jake Jake Allison Jake's going
to practice us throwing this week um and
and you're going 80 and I was like you
could see and this is like when the sers
this is thorny mcco see like everyone
and I was like oh [__] you're ready but
knowing Coy he probably did that on
purpose cuz he love he's such a l he'd
always give guys an opportunity I
remember he did it for um Lawrence
Colette when he didn't get an
opportunity David Hall same thing true
yeah man um yeah yeah so delber spent
the night in the Sals for you yeah so
mate I went 80 but um that and that was
my only St and only really time I played
but I uh looky back on it played played
the best game I've probably played um
but I got to play 82 so I really got
into it and then uh over the next year
or so I only played two or three games
and then the rebels kicked off that's
right um and I was like man I've I've
had a bit of a taste for it I've been on
the edge um I needed I needed to find
some but this was the times too when you
could only really get picked within your
franchise so you know now the everyone
just gets picked to the best but I was I
was in the Hurricanes franchise The Log
Jam in front of you so I I was either
stay here and wait or or shoot off
outside of New Zealand at that stage M
so the rebels came in it was the best
thing I ever did yeah yeah so um you
grew up in Wellington right grew up in
Wellington yeah so Wellington born and
bread like wanted to play for the
Hurricanes lions that was who I was so
even after two years to leave that was
like man like this is but I'm 27 by this
age I was a batler like I played 100
games of Club rugby before I even really
got a opportunity I was the old school
yeah yeah yeah so um cuz out of school I
did get offered an academy contract with
the Hurricanes Wellington at that stage
CU they don't they didn't even do superm
at that stage taking the spe um and then
but I was a cricketer too so I was I was
playing good cricket and was like came
out was like man do I want to pursue
Cricket do I want to pursue R I'm not
sure so I said look can I have a year
like give me a year um I'm not sure to
think about it yeah to think about it
all right that's a tough decision yeah
man because a year so I said look I want
to play a season of Club rugby I want to
keep going cricket and then come back to
you so did the year out and sadly to
Cricket the pathway in that in that age
group it's just there's not a lot and
still isn't you either you know you play
Under NS try and make New Zealand n and
then you got to try and get to First
Class there's no real so did you play
New Zealand 19 I I made the squad the 24
men Squad um so this is Ross Taylor
Jesse Ryder and they we had a trial down
here at Lincoln and I think I went like
10 overs 1 for 85 and and Jesse and Ross
just went berserk but they went berserk
on everyone cuz they were just so you're
a bowler bowler left arm Orthodox oh wow
mate I'm way outside the norm so I was a
chunky little fat little white boy
bowling little left arm door knobs and
then so I go to Cricket and they go mate
you're too big and then I go to ragby
and they go you got to be bigger too so
I was like living in the in between how'
you go with the bat uh at a like at a at
a first 11 level I could had it well but
at that level I was 9 or 10 and yeah
could noodle it off the hip and play a
little gu shot and that was that was
about it but um good Fielder and and
just talk crap and so I I was going all
right and I was like man I'm not sure
did the year and then went now I'll go
back I think Rugby's it so went into the
academy manager said hey mate I made a
decision I'm ke to get back and he goes
uh we we don't want you anymore and I
was like a right to the soul eh they
said you're too slow you're fat you're
chunky you're too slow one past they
call me which I got told my whole life
one past and then they said no mate we
we don't want you anymore more and I
just was like oh what have I done yeah
did you try and go back to Cricket at
this point well I was still playing
Cricket but I I don't know this is
partly what we'll talk about as we go on
I think um I had a framework in my mind
when anyone told me I wasn't good I was
like I always kind of wanted not wanted
to prove them wrong but I Ed I use that
kind of anger or sadness to go okay I'm
going to get better cuz I want to prove
you wrong no and and I was still a
batler like I wasn't like cozy I didn't
have this I had the fundamentals of an
Old School Hooker I was like Shan I was
just all about effort yeah yeah and and
that was me really um and then so I was
oh no okay I I'll go I'll go train I'll
start training and like really put it in
because this was the problem when I
looked back on it was I wasn't all in on
Cricket and I wasn't all in on Rugby so
I was just kind of the in between yeah
so how do I how did I expect to get
better in either of them if I wasn't
really fully committing to either yeah
what would you have done differently
there committed to W when you got that
Academy opportunity I don't know I like
at the time when at that time I was said
man I should have taken it the year
before but again I don't know if I'd be
even here talking to you right now
unless I did that that year yeah to to
fuel me to go all right I I can still do
this like I can prove you wrong and then
that kind of gave me a little chip on
the shoulder to and then I trained
better that year and then did well the
end of the year and then they come back
to me so this is three almost 3 years
out now they go oh no J now we want you
I was like oh I I'm in now and that was
you self-driving all of that
self-driving all that yeah so yeah like
we know right in terms of like the high
performance if you're not if you're not
driven like you're not get you're not if
you're not willing to put it in that's
not going to happen and I was always
going to be that effort Drive guy over
anything else because I waddled I I was
had this like waddle I ran terribly
everyone was like the coaches would come
up after 10 minutes G you look like you
played 80 minutes and I be like oh noce
I just waddle that's me running fresh
yeah it is I had this waddle and I was
like do I have a short leg and like no
you don't have a short leg you just
waddle um yeah so that so that kind of
fueled me so then yeah if we go back so
the Hurricanes kind of work that way
through battled and played really well
on that one Crusaders game and then
effectively that got me the contract in
Rebels that one game the year before so
I'd heard um so Adam friy was their kind
of Marquee signing for the for the
rebels that stage yeah but he was he was
on the outer and I reckon he signed for
for money more than play and he BW us
back out oh yeah so it must be getting
towards the end of that Wellington Li
season and then they were just looking
for another hooker and then they said I
found out later on that they went to
Chrono so the coach knew uh the Ford's
coach Mark bwell knew Chrono well and
said who's the best hooker in New
Zealand that's not signed yeah and he
said well it's j cuz I was the last one
left yeah so I got a one-year deal at
the rebel so I was like M I can't yeah I
do I stay here at the Hurricanes behind
Coy and Hy or do I go to the rebels yeah
on a one-year deal 100% I'm gone like
I've got to see what I got um and that
was the best thing I did because all
that laring of training that I had done
up into that stage I got an opportunity
to play regular minutes regular and I I
played the best rugby I've ever played
in my life because I had the opportunity
to play but I had all that stacking of
training to allow me to to open that
door and see what it was and we actually
bet the canes in Melbourne that year did
you well that was the year that Hammet
took over yeah yeah yeah so um obviously
there was a lot going on in the
background and the boys Wen probably at
their best but um yeah I played awesome
against the canes but I I was you know
like I was hungry to go you're right up
for that
one yeah press wrong yeah so B thing and
then I signed an extra couple of
years so I had three years and was
playing all the time and earning better
money there than I would here um and was
like and then I got into a decision [__]
I've I've G done really well here for
three
years and now Kevin Mamu and Hy are
coming towards the end so this is coming
up to 215 World
Cup and I'm I'm 30 though so I'm like
[__] do I come back and like see if I
can really have a dig at this for the
214 season see if I can potentially be
an all black cuz like I would have even
though that was my dream I was like I
don't know thought you like even though
I wanted to be there but after playing 3
years and going [__] I'm actually going
all right if I do this in New Zealand I
could be in the mix I
reckon um and then so um and this is
another long story ended up at the
Highlanders so Hy
retires pushed out retired depends how
you look at it um with Jamie Joe after
their 23 year when they signed everyone
in and then they came last yeah so we
played the hollanders in the last game
of the that 213 season and then I get
the old J Jo you know Jamie Joe stor so
Flex me an email goes J I can I can even
say
how J I'm in we're in you know we're
playing catch up for a coffee you know
like oh yeah okay okay Jamie cuz I had
Jamie at the line so I knew what was
coming yeah he sat down and goes yeah
H's H's going to retire or we're going
to make him retire depends how you look
at it um k k to have you next year yeah
what do you reckon what do you reckon I
was like oh yeah I'm interested could
you with Jamie man like this big guy in
front of you I'm 30 though like I'm like
I know and I'm like yes I'd kind of keep
it close to my chest yeah yeah I'm
pretty Keen pretty interested and I'd
sign back with Hawks Bay coming back oh
yeah tried to go to the lines but um
they were they were all ready so came
back to there and then um yeah so as the
season went on he kept emailing said
yeah mate we're just sign you we're just
sorting out the Horry stuff we're going
to sign you I was like [__] this is
taking a bit more time than I thought
got to like the day before the cut off
date and he flicks me an email and goes
oh mate uh sorry mate we're we're out of
celery C money we can't sign you anymore
and I was
like and I and he just sent me an email
too and I was darker oh true because
everyone else everyone else was signed
up like he had verbally told me three or
four times mate you got it we just we
just got to sort it out and then he goes
oh but we can take you on waterer and
I'm like mate like I've just left
$200,000 a year at the rebels to come
home for this and you want to give me a
40 Grand contract at waterer
and I was like um so that took it back
but I had to take it like oh you took it
I had no Rebels couldn't wouldn't take
you back well funly enough the day
before I was supposed to drive down for
preseason training [__] no one knows
this I got a call from the rebels game
mate would you come back like yeah I was
probably going to be Captain leadership
group like it was a big quarter come
back yeah really good money but it's
like I had to keep thinking backward
what was my Boyhood dream why was I here
I wanted to be an all black right did
the Wes ever cross your mind cuz
obviously it would have been three years
at that point I played like 3 minutes
for the junior blacks oh yeah so again
that 2909 year when I played that one
game for the Crusaders Colin Cooper was
coach yeah and then he was New Zealand
Junior coach at that stage um and then
there was about 27 hooker in
Greece so um I got the call up against
FG and played two minutes off the bench
and got capped and got capped so um but
I mean it might have been different
going over I was new like New Zealand is
who I am I don't even think and
everyone's got their different reasons I
don't I would I would have said no even
if I they said yes um I was in probably
talk for Australia a the ones that
didn't know that I played but I I would
have said no I I don't think I could
play against the old blacks um yeah so I
came back and then I and then and then
the rebels called me the day before I
was supposed to go down to the
Highlanders and they're like mate come
back we'll we'll give you 150k comeback
and I was like 40K
150k doing the mess a bit better just
had had I had a baby of 9 months old
wife had moved back you know the story
mate and I was like but why am I here
it's not actually about the money um it
is but it's not was your wife loving
Melbourne she loved Melbourne but we had
just had it when we were in Melbourne we
had no kids so it's different and then
we come back to and then we had had our
son and I was like what do we do I think
um but again we spoke about it and I was
like why did we come back in the first
place you came back here to chase your
dream um what's money for that yeah so I
was like okay but the the biggest
problem for me was I um I held on to
that angs with Jamie a lot for that
whole season like I was I was pretty
dark at him I never let him know that at
the time because I wanted to
play but it probably affected me because
I was just I was really angry at him
angry at how went down and that probably
set with my values I I was um yeah just
felt like it could have been done a lot
different even if you had just called me
and told me the situation yeah um yeah
so and then that that year I actually
played all right Cy L cman was going
pretty well too and this is the year
before dicko Ash Dixon came down um and
yeah so probably started five or six
games and went all right but not enough
to be an all black and then um when did
you know that like when did you know the
World Cup dream was over H I mean I mean
that was a 214 year and I went all right
and I still thought if I could play
regularly but I was my body was probably
starting to tell me I was getting
getting to I mean 31 now um and then I
played a ride against the Crusaders that
year for the Landers and you love the
Crusader you love playing against the
crus everyone does though right like you
got it like that's that's the Pinnacle
we still are right we not from the
inside now from the outside we got to go
like this is it
um and then thorny was playing for the
Landers at that stage and fny was
leaving just fny on so then thorny kind
of rang here and said hey this guy's not
bad um he'd probably be good to come up
here with flyy leaving um so that kind
of started that conversation to come
here so you can see why I moved I didn't
move cuz I wanted like I yeah I wanted
to St out the Landers cuz they got the
culture right but I found it really hard
because of what had happened with Jamie
so I almost in spite of myself said I'm
not playing for you anymore in my head
yeah and and didn't pursue that but then
dicko dicko was coming too and look what
Dio's done at the Highlanders and where
he was going so it's easy for me to say
if I stayed there I would have played
but yeah Ash was unbelievable and lader
he became down there and who he was so
it's always easy for me to say yeah so
came here and Cody was kicking off
really um so I came here wanting to play
and then realized pretty soon that I was
only here as cover how did you know that
just CU just a different turn of pace
was it
uh yeah well Cody Cody was that year he
kind of was just coming it like it was
it was H and Benny forel's
turn but when I when I had spoke to them
I said look I'm only coming if it's it's
all on for all of us like I'm not I'm
not coming here just to be your
cover but I was so I was probably dark
again I was like just tell me the truth
man like um so yeah came here and the
career probably just whittled away in
the last couple years and it was
probably a bit of a disappoint in last
couple years for me but Cody Cody
deserved what he got he was he was like
Coy he had he had expector that yeah I
didn't have I was the I was the battler
that waddled along and could make 20
tackles and Cody's line breaking so and
they playing on the edge and I don't
play on the edge I'm around the rock
doing my thing and running your Jelly
Bean L lot of requests about the Jelly
Bean L yes I love it talk to me about
that one yeah mate so um and that
probably speaks to how I play like I was
even though I was slow and fat and throw
a allall in and that was about it I had
I was probably like snaky a little bit I
Pro I had a good understanding from the
game and anticipation I could see things
yeah so I probably had a mind of a team
but was in a
body um so at the reels cuz I was
playing regularly I started seeing
shapes of defense and what was going on
and we played a lot of RA off nine I was
going M this's this like this with
vision you know everyone's looking up
and your head on a swivel you know what
we talking about look up
straight but there's this periphal bit
around when you're on the D especially
when you're around the rock where you've
got to watch nine and you've got to
watch first runner M so you you can't
see out the side right out the side of
your your eye yeah and I was like well
what if I just ran flat across the dline
and they can't actually see me yeah um
and I was like oh yeah okay this and um
so then I we started practicing at
training pre season and we actually
played canes in the preseason I scored
two tries off it and I like man this is
me this is going to be my trademark so
many people that jelly be like yeah so
then um yeah so I I always said it's the
like it's the undefendable line yeah and
then everyone cracked up I said no it's
not it's true and then so when I played
for the Landers I scored against the
Crusaders for it and this just became my
line yeah but then after a while
everyone knew that that's where I just
stood start so I'd Wadd along on the
line and then just kind of do a little
banana or jelly
the um so that just kind of became my
tradar and sort of gone out of the game
since you left yeah I know it's my thing
I'm back coaching the bide so I'm trying
to bring it back but as a gutsy line cuz
you're almost offside and it's like it's
and you've got to get your halfbacks
online but yeah that kind of became my
little jelly be trademark I do remember
it I do remember it
well so then what was next for you after
um the Crusaders yeah so uh ended
216 knew that last contract was probably
that was I was going into retirement did
you ever look at Japan or overseas or I
did but the problem was Japan at that
stage didn't take any front rowers yeah
so it's only just changed in probably
the last five or six years yeah so even
when I was retiring Jake Allison who's
made of mine he had to go back to flaner
to go to Japan yeah so he changed he was
a loose head prop and and used to play
flanker and then he signed as a flanker
that could play prop just so he could
get his money get over there um so they
didn't take anyone but I I lost if I was
going to go the best time was to go was
after the rebels cuz I was playing
regularly my people could say I was
played my worth was up but I came back
and then played seven games over three
years starting and so I kind of got out
of and then the body started getting a
few neck issues and pain down my arm and
old DE gave me the old you got x-r and
said how long you playing for J I was
said I'm probably retiring IND year she
it's probably a good
so I was the writing was on the ward
wall but probably the other thing as you
know is my mindset had changed probably
towards the end and I hate to think back
on it but I probably had stopped trying
to be my best towards the end I was I
was there because I'd signed but I
wasn't playing I knew it was coming
towards the end and then the body
started breaking down but I think the
body started breaking down because I
wasn't fully 100% into trying to be my
best anymore um and it's I don't like
saying it because it wasn't who I was as
a person but looking back on that last
part I was I was probably not taking a
paycheck but I was just doing enough to
get by interesting point around like
mentally checking out before you
physically like everyone talks about oh
your body you're slowing down now you
past your 30s but you see guys Welling
to their late 30s who obviously still
mentally are switched on around
everything whereas I was like you I
believe I had a dodgy hit but mentally
started finding it really hard and you
just see
everything deteriorate pretty quickly eh
yeah and that and that probably taught
me a little bit about the mindset and
stuff and what we'll talk about soon
around how how we structured it's
actually called positive aging would you
believe so you know like we had you know
rugby terms you had 30 you're an old
bugger everyone's like mate you're old
you're 30 and then so you start living
into this I'm 30 I'm almost done yeah
and then I could see the transition of
my mind and that started actually
playing out in the body um yeah so then
retired and if you look back on my
career I would have been said that I was
actively ready for after rugby when did
that start for you probably I really
started holding down when I was here
yeah so the last two years cuz I knew it
was coming I had two years to kind of
get ready yeah um but even pre that I I
actively used my PD time I you know like
if we did promos I was the one that got
up and talked cuz I was a guy that could
talk and I kind of actively tried to
partner with people doing work yeah so I
was I was probably not a poster boy but
I was one that would go jib will be
sweet you know like cuz he's he's good
and he knows who he is and yeah and you
doing I was just talking to Matt Todd on
the coach's office before and you had a
lot of like side hustles too didn't you
like lots of different businesses and
tried all sorts of different things and
that all talk yeah so um but I was
searching yeah I was searching for what
was next for me without understanding
who I was and what really drove me so I
was I ended up starting a food truck up
after I retired I I love food I love
food so um and I always make pizzas for
the boys oh man I should kick off a
pizza truck and I had a mate who was had
a cafe over in pepo and I was like he's
like oh I chck the pizza truck out FR
front so I did some numbers I could do
this yeah but again it was um and I had
it for 5 years but it came a little side
catering good and it was really good
good for me it taught me heaps about
small business uh got to go into heaps
of people's houses when they're having
parties and at their best and enjoying
themselves and I made pizzas for them um
again I was I was searching for
something without really having as you
spoke about with you around that
self-awareness I didn't really have an
understanding cuz I was sad I was sad
that I had finished but I didn't know
why I I knew I wasn't sad that I wasn't
playing
anymore but I couldn't decide if I was
sad because I didn't have a job or I
didn't know what my next purpose was or
so I was kind of like waiting through
and
my wife is a GP um but she wasn't she
was training to be a GP so we knew when
I was retiring that she needed to be
through her training by the time we had
finished because that if we didn't have
her working I didn't know what I was
doing what I was going to earn I'm not
from Christ Church we staying here if I
went back to Wellington I probably would
have picked up something cuz that was
where my support network was yeah so she
the last couple years of me playing it
was pretty challenging cuz she was doing
all her study um and we were we had two
kids so she was trying to get all the GP
done so she could be a GP when we
finished which was hard for her as well
and doing all the study so the day that
I crossed over and retired she kind of
took over and became the breadwinner in
the house um and was doing two uh three
days a week and then I was trying to
find the next the next thing yeah um yes
I was geez I had a I start up a little
to Pal trying to sell little pals with
people I have a bit of entrepreneurial
mind but I was like what but there
wasn't much meaning and purpose it I was
like I was just doing it for the sake of
it a little bit which is but I needed to
probably work through that and and then
I got to about 3 years out and had
learned as we do we learned heaps about
our mind and how it works how it helps
us be our best on the field and I was
really like fascinated in growth mindset
what that looked like what why how I use
it in my career to help me get to where
I was as a battler yeah um and started
reading Heats more towards in in my
career about positive psychology and
then was like man how can I study this
and I was like and the place to do it is
University of Pennsylvania I'm like I
can't go to America and do a PhD like
hundreds of thousands of dollars I got
this stage three kids in New Zealand I'm
like what what do I I can't do that and
then I heard through the great find that
um there's a diploma in positive psych
um run by New Zealand Institute of
wellbeing and resilience yeah so A lady
called Dr Lucy hone and Dr Denise
quinland Lucy Hon's famous cuz she's got
a TED Talk actually on here how she used
um sadly her daughter died in a car
accident when she was about 11 years old
um and she used the positive psychology
techniques to help her um
grieve um and there's a really awesome
podcast on that so I was like man I've
got to do this diploma I've got to see
I've got to this is a chance for me to
learn a bit more and see what it's about
so yeah almost three years ago um I did
the diploma and Denise quinland ran it
um and it was flipping unbelievable for
me um it just the amount of light bulb
moments of oh this is that this is what
I was searching for when I retired and
getting way more self-awareness around
why I was sad what was going on and I
was like man this this is it like and
then it was and I was like I've got to
do something with
this and then um and it' be interesting
to talk to you about like how did you
find it when you retired like how did
you find when you crossed over that day
and it was done how did how did you find
it all all happened really quickly for
me like I went straight from I had hip
surgery went straight from playing to
coaching basically within that week so
um was real fast and always felt like I
was still in that environment but I
always talking to all the players who
have been on and just that
instant geez what what now and um lack
of purpose lack of identity those are
real common things that sort of pop up
missing the boys missing the changing
room the camaraderie and all that sort
of thing that everyone loves about the
game but um you think you've got heaps
of good friends and then you're not
playing and they're all still friends
but you're sort of out of that Circle so
totally yeah yeah um and it's and it's
probably good for you because you you
got to stick into the environment a
little bit by coaching yeah I was lucky
how it worked out for me but yeah um
yeah so and that was probably so this
the model that they use and it's um it
comes from Martin Seligman who's like
the the Richie mccor of positive side
he's like go go um and it's it's around
and it's similar to Timmy's around there
there's five key areas they talk about
and then there's another one um Vitality
which is kind of add on it's called the
Perma Perma model and the five key areas
the first one's around positive emotion
yeah so if we look and when we're
playing um how much positive emotion do
we have at training we play games the
laughter the humor the
enjoyment uh playing regularly like
positive emotion is here all the time um
and you don't realize what what guys
don't realize and this is a
self-awareness piece a whole heap of
what happens in a sporting environment
or a rugby team is actually really
quality well-being stuff but we do it
because we need it for high performance
but it's actually High performing in
terms of flourishing in life as well
yeah um because the thing is about
positive emotion it's not saying we need
to be in positive emotion all the time
but resilient people don't get stuck in
one emotion they don't get they don't
get sad or glum all the time and just
get stuck there they can they can come
out of it and so if we have a bad game
and we're a bit sad or glum or we get
injured but then we come to training and
we're back into the next phase of what
we've got to do because we've got a goal
goal to get to we're having you know
many team games we're having lunches
together so that's that's actually doing
all the positive emotion for us but we
don't realize at the time it's making us
feel good because of that yeah um and
then the next one around it the P models
engagement
so engagement means how much you're
engaged in what you're doing on a
day-to-day now and that's like in the
zone or the flow stuff that you know
everyone talks about so and when I when
I finished the course I was like that's
why I reckon I was almost mostly said
because why did we play rugby or sport
from the first places we just flipp and
loved it right yeah like when we went
out on that field it didn't matter if I
was 5 or 26 like I was in it like I was
zoned in to what we were doing I was
focused and that's engagement so and and
so all that good stuff that was
happening to me was cuz and then the day
it stopped and it still happens for you
I've probably just lost 10 hours of of
Flow State or engagement in my week that
I didn't even know was part of my life
yeah and it's like oh man so I started
going that's why I was sad I've got no
engagement yeah and then and then the
next ones that are is relationships so
you talked about it before the Inner
Circle the boys relationships and what
we know now well what they know is
around um anyone that like thrives or
flourishes in Li the number one
predictor is the amount of quality
relationships and connections they have
interesting that is the number one so we
go day one I said hey guys guys I'm
retired the next day I'm gone all that
relationship or connection is pretty
much gone it's done yeah so you go back
to your your support networks with your
family and that so there is some of that
but I've just lost a whole chunk of it
how do you how do you stop that yeah so
it's good question so the the key things
is is one having an understanding then
that's going to be really important um
so when that day go so what is so before
we get to that stage I would love to be
meeting with everyone and going what
does your support network look like when
you do retire instead of saying do you
retire how you going oh they've got a
family they're okay yeah but then part
of what I want to deliver when we build
this course which we're going to get to
built this course is whoever comes on
the course and they've just retired
hopefully now they've got a cohort of
people that they've just retired with so
part of the glory of doing the course is
not just the course now there's
hopefully 20 people that are in the same
Journey that can now connect and be
together and be the next team that
they're in yeah because now I've just
got people that are in the likeminded
situation with me that can support me
but we can hang out and and spend time
in for the ones that are in the same
area or if that's online or whatever it
is I've just built a cohort to help you
through that because that's and then as
developing techniques to really enhance
the relationships you ever had you have
in your environment at the moment and
and increasing those and and really kind
of leaning into those relationships
because you're going to need them
because you've just lost a whole chunk
of them yeah fascinating real
fascinating and then the next one is M
the meaning and
purpose and this is a little bit around
identity and and where we're at
because
all the studies say you know like you
don't let what you do as a job wrap you
up as your identity but I kind of call
[__] on that a little bit because
when we're trying to be our best in high
performing environments and we are all
in like we speak about you canot be
wrapped up in that yeah like you can't
not say that I'm I'm trying to be an all
black I love this this is who I am yeah
so it's hard to unpack that when you
retire and say I'm not that anymore but
getting an understanding more about who
you are as a person so you know how like
we always learn in rugby you know I have
a real good understanding on what type
of player I am MH but if I asked you
what type of person are you could you
answer that it's a lot tougher isn't it
way tougher e so what values do you live
by what what who do you want to be as a
person we always get told who do you
want to be as a player yeah but why
aren't we asking who do you want to be
as a person because they're both the
same thing yeah so now if you ask me I'm
a man that wants to have kindness for
people that wants to always grow and has
the love of learning um wants to have
some joy and humor in my life and that's
those those are my values and I exuded a
lot of those while I was playing but I
had never an I didn't have an
understanding that's why I was doing
those because that's who I was yeah so I
was I was the culture guy right I was a
guy that always sorted out the team
games cuz I loved it I love but I was
also the guy of some was injured I would
go and sit beside them because I wanted
to be kind to them because I could see
that they were struggling and like at
the rebels if a new guy came into the
team cuz we were playing in Melbourne
they always had to flying from Sydney so
I was the one that went and picked them
up from the airport yeah that wasn't my
job I was a player yeah but I knew oh
man that guy's coming over he's going to
be struggling yeah like this is a new
environment why didn't one of us a
player going pick him up because that's
going to make him feel better MH and
then he's going to have more of a chance
to be better for us on the field instead
they get a taxi to pick him up chucking
in a hotel next to the park by himself
well you can't do that yeah but but I
couldn't figure out why I was thinking
that and then no one else was you're a
lad yeah yeah and that's the thing is so
like when Scotty fuger staller came over
so me and Scotty mates and Jay Woodward
they had signed I've been at the Rebels
for two years they signed um and I was
like mate come live with me like spend
the first time get yourself sorted but I
I did that cuz I was kind and I cared
about them and I knew that would help
them because I had struggled when I got
over there yeah um and it's it's just
it's common sense when you look back on
it yeah yeah so the meaning and purpose
thing is the more awareness we can get
about who we are and our values and who
we want to be so it took me five years
of retiring to figure out that my
mission in life now is to help people on
their mission as simple as that so if
you come to me and say J man I want to
be the best person I want to can be I'm
M I'm with you how can I help because
that's that's that's my me and purpose
and I'm helping you now yeah and and
that if that's mentoring kids that want
to be their best and that's some of the
job I do now um if yeah can be in any
realm but if you're coming to me and say
I want to be my best at at sport or in
life I'm here to help you that's that's
my mission and that's kind of with the
charity that we've started up with
better man it's around helping PE men be
their best and I want to help you on
that journey and then the last one's
accomplishment so that's the a yeah so
what are we do in a rugby environment
we're always trying to Lish a goal or be
our best individually or as a team so I
have a goal I want to make the the
Wellington lies the Hurricanes be in all
black I want to win that trophy so we're
accomplishing stuff um in the gym I'm
getting a better score I want to get my
bench up like we are living with having
a goal hitting it keep going having a
goal hitting it so this Perma model
that's actually about flourishing in
life is what we live with in a in a
rugby environment yeah without even
knowing without even knowing it so most
of the time people are at their best in
that environment because all those
things are getting ticked off and they
don't even know it but then they
retire it's it's all it most of it's
gone yeah so everyone's like oh what's
next but we're so high performing in our
career why can't we be like that when we
finish and it's changing our mindset
about it right because I don't know what
you thought did you and I suppose with
you changing straight to coaching it was
a little bit different but my mindset
was I've made my most money I've I've
conquered that mountain and that's the
best it's gone the best of what I've
done has gone yeah I was a little bit
like that I always but I was a little
bit like you as well and the fact that
people would always tell me you'll be
fine after rugby because I'd always be
really engaged in the PD sessions I'd
always do my own stuff um and I was
always aware o of the end point and I
always thought it would come probably
sooner than it did and I never really
thought I'd get as far as I did so I was
always preparing for it but um yeah how
it did work out for me I was I was very
fortunate but um yeah it is tough it's
such a tough one because you can't
really do stuff I know you did your
pizza company but it's pretty hard to
set something up while you're still
playing cuz playing is fulltime you know
you can't you're all in you can't really
try and grow a business like you can but
um it's going to be very half fast and
it's a good way to learn and try and do
things but you can't like Go full all
into what you want to set up totally
agree because you have to be single
focused to be our best in that
environment so people are like why
aren't you doing more I but they've got
to be single focused though they they
have to focus on what this is because
it's we're going to war like this this
is what we're doing without the death
but that's that's the mentality like
unless you're in it it's hard to explain
to people it doesn't it's not like that
yeah um injuries are a good chance to
definitely step back yeah give it a go
so is that where you did you have many
injuries where you s no luckily I I had
a lot of little ones but nothing nothing
big where I was you Rec on my shoulder
and I needed 6 months off anyway so um
but I probably the different thing for
me was cuz it started
later um I was I was probably um I had a
diploma I already had a diploma in exi
science by the time I started and I was
still studying a little bit and I was
working through and so I was probably
further ahead than a lot of guys are now
which makes me more worried because of
what that looks like so yeah so we think
about this Perma model the last one's V
which is kind of Beyond which is
Vitality which is sleep eat and move
yeah so that's what rugby is man it's
sleep eat move so you add in the Perma
but then you look at the V I stop eating
as well I move but not as much um and
then yeah so and then the sleep and then
we don't really focus on our sleep but
that's there but I was
so these all these parts just kind of
dro down to maybe 20% of what they were
at 100% so no wonder we're sad and
struggling but then you add in that I've
got two kids I've got to pay the
mortgage the stresses of life that come
with that I'm not I'm not 20 leaving
unig going I'm transitioning I'm 33 with
kids in a mortgage it's just so loaded
right it's so it's it's a really hard
transition for everybody um and I liked
him when I listened to shos Sho to has
taken heaps of his high performance
characteristics from what he knew as a
player to try and get his head right M
and that's really clever like he's he's
leaving no stone unturned to find out
how he can get himself right and and
it's sad for him because it's such a
hard thing to get right because you
don't know about your head but he's
going I'm going to do everything in my
possibility to get myself right and you
know I play with Shane for a year that's
how he plays like I'm going to do
everything in my power to be my best
he's all in thaty he's all in right so
he's gone okay it's a different it's a
different challenge now but I'm all in
to sort myself out and this is where the
sad thing gets in is he's doing it by
himself
so and this is sad thing and I you can't
blame all in New Zealand Rugby but they
love you why you're why they yours or
theirs they love you while I'm here when
it's about winning championships and
they I'll do anything to break there for
you but when day
ends M it's I don't know about you I
got one email after8 months J how you
gone they knew you would be all right
mate exactly exactly right so I remember
reaching out after eight months to Steve
Simons and going hey mate can you help
me with my CV I'm struggling to find a
job and I was reaching out to him
because there was no one really in that
space and and I get it it's on me like
it's like a job I've left that job but
it's not a job it's I've gone this I've
just battled for someone for 10 years
and given all my life to
it so I think there needs to be changed
and is this why you set up your thing
this is so yeah so I I when I finished
the course I'd already gone I've got to
do something for these retire players
and I finished the course and I went all
right this is it I'm going to take the
best parts of this course and what I've
learned about how it was challenging for
me and let's make this into a two-day
course the athletes who retire I can
come and do and let's help them change
their mindset around what's next cuz
what I believe now is your F second
Mountain should be better than your
first because everything I learned from
that first one just like you yeah all
those characteristics growth mindset
daily training consistency working hard
taking on feedback all that stuff can be
used to make your second Mountain even
better so I want to change anyone that
reti mindset around the next day and
also to say There's Hope for you there's
hope to be better and to take this to
the next age so we've built this two-day
course um which we haven't been able to
get funded to deliver because at this
stage
organizations it's new right so they
they don't know the value in it or they
don't want to Value it it's a hard one
so but it's all bound by science it's
all by The Godfather you know like the
goat of Mary Selman so it's all bound by
science
so I I want to share it and I want to
give it back to the players to say hey
you can do this like this this is
possible and here's the framework let's
use all those characteristics from a new
plane and let's put it into this
framework and make your next part of
your life even better M I love it
because the sad thing is Jimmy um
there's always only 100 about 150
professional players within New Zealand
but that that retirement pools at 600
now so that that pool of 150 staying the
same but this pool is getting bigger and
bigger and bigger and bigger and what we
know is about one in five of that group
will have some sort of Mental Health
Challenge uh dependency on drug gamine
alcohol that's at the bottom of the
cliff but what about all the ones in the
Middle where I sat as well so I wasn't
at that end but this is going to help
anyone in that kind of Continuum to kind
of come out and be better but so
effectively we just look at rugby
players there's 150 of those that are
really struggling have really really
struggled and they're not getting the
support they
need it's crazy yeah sad it's sad
because they loved us while we were
there yeah yeah and is it just for rugby
players or is it for all sports all
sports so I mean Rugby's obviously where
my mind came to start with it um but
it's for All Sports male female anyone
that's looking to transition out of the
game at of any game uh we want to hear
from them we uh we want to get them
involved and um we want to try and start
this course next year
so we'll Chuck it up in the link notes
but we'll have a link to um the website
B man.org NZ with a little Link in there
and just to kind of express your
interest to be on it um and and we'll
kind of look to try and get it um some
sort of funding and support to get it
done and and let's see what we can do
with it and get some people through it
and um show the worth and hopefully
through word of mouth and doing it that
people will go man this is this is
something that wants that should be part
of your contract yeah so when you sign
your contract part of you retiring and
coming through that is you finish with
the two-day transition course like when
you do when you start Super Rugby and
you have the day induction induction you
have a you have a transition finish as
well which is makes a lot of sense he
too
much that's that's the thing right like
I started seeing there going oh is this
is this am I thinking this out is it
more hard than it is I I don't think it
is it's just and everyone transitions in
life through different phases right so
why can't we let them have a better
transition and support that and give
them some of that stuff that they've had
in there and take it through the next
part and is it done online like how does
that work no so well we will have two
options we prefer it to do in in person
so we we we're not sure of the short
like if we can get the funding right
we'll run in different parts one maybe
one of the North Island one in the South
Island um but for the guys overseas we
will look to it can be done online um
but the better ones in person because
it's connection with the cohort you know
it's that relationship building and um
and you know we talk a little bit about
we we're we're taught so much as men and
as rugby players to be strong and brave
and but part of being a man is and this
is why I love the potty so much mate is
it's about being
vulnerable um because that's been a man
too and that's like where do we and
that's becoming more and more normal but
that's probably like what I loved about
Tim and Shane and and she and why I
reached out to you mate was cuz I was
like these guys have been vulnerable and
telling their stories and we can all
learn from this yeah and the more we can
add that part of what it means to be
part of a high performance environment
it's only going to make us better and
it's going to allow us to transition
better and be better players at the time
as
well M it's exciting exciting for what's
ahead especially in that space cuz I
hear it all too often on this how hard
that transition is but I love it how you
speak about the mindset and like being
excited about that next chapter because
I don't think there's too many guys I
know there's a lot of anxiety from
players around [__] what's next like um
what the hell am I going to do but that
excitement of knowing that what you've
learned through your rugby career puts
you in a really good position to make
that next Mountain bigger totally
totally and it's our self-limiting
belief that we have in everything right
so that's part of the course is how do
we sit down and look at the
self-limiting belief we have and go
actually let's change this narrative
let's go no man we can do this and then
hopefully you walk away with some
understanding around and what your
positive emotions will look like I'll
give you a good example actually so when
when I finished the course I was like
man I need some more like engagement in
zone and I I love playing sports like I
love it doesn't matter if it's social
I'm hundies all at night I'm yelling at
everyone but I'm fully engaged in it
right so I like I'll start up a
dodgeball team cuz I was like I can't I
need to do something so I got some dads
from my street there's like five dads in
the street and I the M said let's start
a dodgeball team but I was I was doing a
pure for myself right I like man I I
need I need some like engagement in
sports so I said let's play some Dodge
bought a Dodge going to start doing some
throwing cuz I'm going to throw my arm
out here and then I got a few of the
boys in and we got ended up with about
10 week two I'm going full hundies guy
goes to throw the ball at me and I jump
back and tear both my
Cs and then like like fully tear them
like I thought someone had shot me from
behind and I got down on like on my or
four ws and I like just crawled crawled
off the like played on end noteb crawled
off and you was like what are you doing
mate and I'm like oh man I've torn both
my cares and I crawled off like 30 m to
the net and had to pull the net back and
had to sat there and watch the rest of
the game and I was out for about 8 weeks
and came back and then tore my car half
again but when I was playing I flipping
loved it yeah and then the cool thing
about it was I bought a group of dads
together so this is a connection piece
right so I bought a group of dads
together we started playing then they
started coming around to my house and we
did some workouts yeah and then I made a
little group and then we started hanging
out and then one of the guys had a house
in kakur so we went down there and
played some golf yeah but it actually
all just started for me saying hey I
want to play some dodgeball you want to
jump in yeah and it's called the broader
and build cycle which is a real cool
cycle so you brought in your physical
Resources by playing and that but you
actually brought in your social
resources as well so I did it purely for
me off that course cuz I needed some
engagement ripped my cars out but but
had five gu and then built this little
crew around me and now we've been
working out together and hanging out for
like last three or four years dodgeball
career done done all of them either I
blew my cars out all of them done their
rotators cuz you're trying to throw like
this ball that's like way nothing and
again I was like I'll go in the first
game and I'll take it easy as soon as a
whle went I handies comp and all the
dads are looking at him like run over
there like get up there like I was H
like I didn't even know the game I was
like I just got locked in but but again
if I didn't have that I only learned
that self-awareness 3 years after or
four years after I retired by doing the
course I was like ah damn it why didn't
I start up so imagine when we retired
now we go okay boys we're going to have
this you're going to go into this Indoor
Cricket League when you retire yeah and
there's a huge and it might be some of
the boys that are still playing yeah but
you're still keeping that connection it
sounds it's not hard and the boys
everyone boys love playing different
sports that so I'm still staying
connected I don't lose all my messenger
and WhatsApp groups that day it retires
and byebye sign I'm not going to coffees
with them anymore you know like yeah all
that stuff is actually our wellbeing but
we we don't see it as that yeah right
crazy so good so is it when's it too
early to start or like when would you
suggest to start looking at it like
obviously there's a lot of young guys
coming through when when do they start
really looking at life after sport um I
think the whole way through your career
if we so some of this course that I want
to do for transitioning I'd love to give
to some of the players now so they can
start looking at some of the cuz it's
like a a kitty or a tool of of of things
so when you get injured what are you
going to do to help you bring yourself
back because you're allowed to be flat
but remember I said about resilient
people don't just get stuck in one
emotion so you know some of the boys
that go to their room play Playstation
for 3 weeks and lock themselves away no
wonder they come back and they're still
flat because they're not connected
they're not using any tools and
strategies so I think for me is it's
about
them understanding to have more
self-awareness around what things make
them feel their best so if they can
learn that the whole way through but we
also need to change our narrative around
like I'd love you'd ask the boys to sit
down and do a um and they've done a
little bit about personality you know
the old dots that all everyone talks
about but I'd love them to sit down more
and
go um and I don't know you've heard the
deathbed letter or the retirement letter
so when you retire um what do you if if
an article went in the paper what would
you want it to say cuz now you start
unpacking what actual values are that
they're not going to say I want to be an
all black they might say one p yeah one
pasted
wadler but the thing is what what I'm
most proud about when I look back on my
career is actually the person I became
like I can't remember what game I won
and lost and it was actually that I I
was you know under stress learned to be
my best had to go at being who I could
be but also was kind and helped out the
team and picked up guys that's that's a
bit I look back on and most fondly it's
not the guy that was on the field it was
actually the guy off the field that I'm
that I'm most fond about but we don't we
don't talk about that so imagine you've
got an group go boys these are all our
values up on the ward what ones aligned
to who you want to be because that will
still come out in their game MH um so
it's probably teaching them some of this
stuff along the G way so when they do
retire they've got this whole kind of
toolbox already ready yeah to cake them
into the next bet they're allowed to be
s they've just lost they've just
finished their career that they're all
wrapped up in MH but there is a whole
lot more that they can use to help them
bounce back and and go into that next
phase got me thinking about like
injuries like when guys do get that
long-term injury whether there is
something like a day course or something
for them to you know jump in and say
okay like I'm out for 12 months 9 months
let's start looking planning for this
next chapter yeah and then so and that's
the thing like the more more we can
embed you know the old IP yeah you know
like um individual performance plan for
the people that don't know like this
gold you know like green red orange
whatever they want to use but imagine if
that IP had a lot more around so this is
what you need to do technically and
technically what are you doing to be
resilient off field so um yeah like and
a good another good example is I
remember with Jamie Joe when I was at
the Lions I um fractured my eye socket
jally thrush need me in my own team oh
absolute grab
thring need me and then you know FRA My
socket I was out for six weeks or
something and then he run me up and goes
sorry mate you know like you know being
nice and he goes go home and have a
roast with the family mate and and I did
that and it was actually home that's
actually a really good tool yeah so love
food went ah had some food went with the
people in my support network that were
close to me when I was flat and I went
ah had a feed with them and and so that
was actually a tool he didn't know he
was giving me that to he knew I love
food like him so he was like go have a
roast with the family but I I always did
that so whenever I was flat I'd go home
to moms and have a feed and be with her
yeah so I was actually doing a to that I
didn't even know yeah but it's it comes
back to fostering that self-awareness
again half those boys don't realize that
they go in their room and do you know
like lock themselves away and how do we
bring them in and I think I remember
hearing about you like you went straight
in your engine you want to help coaching
so you're actually using a tool you're
going how can I help the team these are
my values I love the team I love who
they are M so I can't do it this way but
I can do it this way so I'm going to
come in and step in and help out and
that's you know like you got a few
awards at the canes for who you know
like the person you
were as do you look back fondly on those
Awards like when you yeah more more than
anything really like I'm with you like
it was like games of games at the end of
the day but you always remember the
people um the people that they were the
tours the the laughs all that sort of
thing like you you do remember parts of
games like the guys who like really put
their body on the line for you you
remember those guys but it was all about
what sort of person they were e so it's
funny he and then and then so like when
I look now like I I love looking at art
s AI but I I love the way he plays but I
love the person he is yeah and how he
interacts like I was uh watching the
thing when you know when fuzzy was they
going through that and he he was the one
and rang him up and said hey mate like
this is a player doing this I was like
far out this guy's awesome like seen
through all the the [__] and gone I care
about this man I I want to I want to
look after him um but we don't open a
light to that enough we kind of go yeah
it's always like he's this brutal guy on
the field flipping is but what a man off
the field to live by that kind of values
and and network and I want the players
to Aspire to be their best on the field
but also to Aspire to be their best off
it with the stuff as well and to learn
more about it instead of
yeah just kind of waing through and not
really understanding that they're doing
all this good stuff and I feel like guys
like Ai and all that coming out just
going to inspire the Next Generation
look at kisi as well that guy carries
himself like a true champion of right
what he is off the field and what he
believes and what he stands for it's
like you hear him speak and you just
can't not be inspired by it and you can
only imagine how many like um young kids
coming through it's awesome to have
those role models for these guys totally
agree and they're and they're shining a
light on a different scent which we
having having in the past yeah um and
probably as you know is and the hard
thing about this is and a lot of people
will look at or listen and go oh all
these all blacks will be okay they've
got lots of money yeah but that's only
the top 40 yeah you know like I I
retired and had half a house paid off
which is way above everyone else yeah
and that's it like I probably averaged
$120,000 a year or something over my
career me to which I'm purely grateful
for that to have a house but then I
still had a morgage and three kids at
that stage and that's it I wasn't in
that top 40 yeah there's only 40 of
those 110 are battling away yeah so it's
such a different variance and what about
the ones that only just get to the NPC
level like what about them yeah yeah or
the ones that bail out from Academy and
they're done like there are so many
layers to this um and everybody needs it
in different ways but all needed and
I'll shout out to Coy here um but I'd
love to Coy to do it I think it would be
awesome for Coy you go free pass to D
you well he decided to go to Japan and
make millions of dollars in the last
four months anyway um I I loved it when
I saw the I saw him on thing they said
you know the wife said do it of course
wife said do it it's only four more
months yeah but yeah so like that and
and that's what I I think when I sat
there and I looked around the room when
I was retiring and I don't know if
you're the same I looked around the room
and I went he'll be okay he won't he'll
be okay he won't and I was like this is
this is crap man like this is we why am
I why am we leaving this up to chance
like it's it's not right yeah um and we
and we only hear about the stories and
the papers and you know like Bill and
it's flipping sad man and they're the
one in five that I spoke about and so
there's a whole lot up there and there's
a whole lot in the middle that needs
support too um and we can do something
about it
mate you're doing good things so thanks
it's been a while it's taken it's a
journey to get here right like um again
I I wish I found the course earlier but
I don't know if I'd be here either if it
didn't take three or four years to me to
Wade through all that stuff to go come
on we can you know like this this is it
and I'm lucky now cuz Denise quinland
and Lucy are kind of my mentors now so
I've I've got I've stepped out of that
environment into this incredible
environment and these two people to kind
of support me along with well-being
Works which is a company that's part of
them A lady called Kim T who's helped me
develop the course um so it's using my
experiences as a player the
understanding I've learned from the
diploma but then using experts to go
okay how do we bring this all together
um and and have a crack and and see what
it can do and help people yeah looking
forward to the wad effect taking over
from here we've seen it with Tim
Batman's books Cody's a clips now P
players come on come on come on water
yeah do
thing anyway we've gone to our questions
um got a few goodies here we'll see we
got through a few of them actually but
um how many times did Jamie Joseph say
no good to me to
him no good in bread and butter so bread
and butter was this down and UPS man the
amount of times he told me no good I
still remember a time when I got injured
on the ground and we were doing a drill
yeah he said no good to me and he just
moved the drill like I was quite injured
the physio did come and he just kind of
pushed me onto the ground and walked
over there yeah and another time I um we
were doing lifting training this was
Wellington Beast days I had no mouth gut
and at the end of training and we're
doing lifting and the Lock's gone to
jump and he's upad of me and knocked my
front tooth out oh [__] and crashy again
no I wish it was knocked my tooth out
and he's looked at me and said come on
mate and I'm on the ground trying to
find my front tooth and he's like you're
no good to me and I had to and I walked
off trying to find my tooth and had to
go to the dentist
ruthless
oh he was
ruthless oh he is okay next one
um would love to get his thoughts on his
Cricket coaching career specifically
making year n's cry cuz they couldn't
catch a high
ball who said that one through when I
was when I retired oh when I was 18 or
19 I coached the Wellington under 13
Cricket s yeah and I remember going out
there and I got golf balls and all sorts
and I was just cuz they're all scared of
catching the ball and I was okay we'll
go for an hour and I was just smashing
the ball and they're all catching I was
said do it again I was probably
channeling a bit of Jamie Joe when I was
18 being
inspired okay next one was he really
convinced that he had the best bacon and
egg pie at the Marist Albi and Pie comp
2017 100% I did like cuz I backed my
baking in there the piz stuff so they
did I coached there in 27 they do a
bacon and egg competition yeah and they
gave me third it was bull crap I think
it was just cuz I was here coach a like
I got shafted I definitely had the
one free range IGS the whole the whole
range whole
lot okay um next one what was your
thoughts on the Move Apple obviously we
heard about the Apple move on Denny
sani's one 15 man picking go yeah I I
have to give this part to SI as I like
um we we did joke about it a lot that
what are we doing like CU Rod talked
Lots about changing the game change the
game and then this apple slice move came
out um but probably the difference
between us and Danny we didn't front the
coach in front of everyone kind of it's
my first year I was doing what I told
yeah you would have been all four a
packing get a jelly bean line there I I
set up two tries from the slice from it
in the end it took about 3 years but I
was doing what I was talking about I had
to I was trying to get a contract and
stay there I wasn't keep I wasn't being
S
as fair enough okay last one best piece
of advice for a wad
listener um I mean I I've probably spoke
about it is um I think we got to think
differently about how how we are as
people and it's not about what we do
it's about who we are and it's deep um
but I'd love us to think more about who
we want to be as people and exude those
values more and and the rest take care
of itself um you know when you meet
people you always go hey mate what do
you do yeah we start asking hey M who
who do you want to be like what what
kind of makes you who you are and where
you from and that's the mold Pacific is
Awesome with that always asking you know
they where you're from and they want to
con to you as a person instead of just
what I do as a job yeah um so it's
diving into that stuff more about who
what your values are what's your meaning
and purpose and trying to really live
live by that mate love it what a way to
finish come on what a podcast come on
the water effect get this thing humming
but mate really appreciate you coming on
reaching out and um mate that was some
unreal stuff there that you've shared
and I know such a big part of the game
so um hopefully there's someone out
there who's got something at it and
they're Keen to come over and jump on
the course and get a real experience
thanks Jimmy and I want to say again
mate like um like I said you in the
email um it it doesn't sit lightly with
me that the giving guys opportunities to
be vulnerable and to tell their story
and I know you probably didn't sit out
with Timmy when you started when he
started kind of unleash this lock of oh
man what's next but appreciate you
having the ability to do it for us and
mate you're you're doing it on this and
with the consistency and and driving it
and and allowing us to kind of show
showcase what people can do so
appreciate it mate M appreciate you
you're a l